xxx back in the Xander zone shutting
down Hollywood Boulevard can you believe
that I mean it is so insane it's huge
it's crazy this is so epic that's a team
I can work with can we just talk about
how gorgeous
Paloma looks tonight I'm sleepless I
mean she's so stunningly beautiful she's
my rock so she's so stunningly beautiful
on the inside she's everything I mean
she's the perfect mother got your hot
date is here tonight you're stunning
girlfriend how amazing is it to share
this incredible epic moment with her she
is the most amazing person and she's
always such a moral support for me and a
moral compass and I'm so glad she came
tonight and short hair I don't care I
love it what inspired this cut I've been
wanting to cut my hair for over seven
years but because I was working I
couldn't I felt like it was time for a
change
to debut and new me fans have found it
very inspirational that we have a strong
female lead who's gay those
relationships exist in life everywhere
but they're not shown in cinema so much
so that was great and after seeing VIN
audition for carpool karaoke con City
iself
Potter family Nina is confident she
could handle it - I like big butts and I
cannot lie you other brothers can't deny
when a girl walks in with an itty bitty
waist and a round thing in your face you
get sprung my homeboys tried to warn me
but that butt you got makes me so horny
you